Wir haben im Ultraschall eine auffällige Stelle in ihrer Schilddröse gefunden.
Um das genauer zu untersuchen, möchten wir eine kleine Gewebeprobe aus der Schilddröse entnehmen.
Oder wir möchten bei Ihnen eine kleine Gewebeprobe aus der Schilddröse entnehmen.
Dies wird mit einer kleinen, sehr dünnen Nadel gemacht.
Dies ist ein risikoarme Routine-Eingriff.
Ich werde Ihnen später noch genauer die möglichen Risiken und Komplikationen erklären.
Sie werden bei dem Eingriff auf dem Rücken liegen, der Hals ist gestreckt.
Wir desinfizieren die Haut im Bereich der Einstichstelle gründlich.
Der Eingriff ist kaum schmerzhaft und entspricht etwa dem Gefühl bei einer Blutentnahme.
Dennoch betäuben wir die Haut mit einer örtlichen Betäubung,
sodass sie eventuell nur ein unangenehmes Gefühl etwas tiefer im Gewebe spüren.
Der Eingriff dauert insgesamt nur ca. 20 Minuten.
Wie bereits erwähnt ist dies ein risikoarme Routine-Eingriff.
In sehr seltenen Einzelfällen kann es zu einer Verletzung von wichtigen Nerven kommen,
was zu dauerhaften Schwierigkeiten beim Sprechen und Heiserkeit führen kann.
Verletzungen von größeren Blutgefäßen oder Nerven sind bei diesem Eingriff aber extrem selten.
Infektionen an der Einstichstelle sind grundsätzlich möglich, aber sehr selten.
Meist lassen sich diese mit Antibiotika-Gutbehandeln nur in sehr seltenen Einzelfällen verlaufen diese schwer
und machen eine längere Behandlung, eventuell auch im Krankenhaus erforderlich.